the presence of a common ion can affect
a solubility equilibrium for example
let's say we have a saturated solution
of lead to chloride lead to lead to
chloride is a white solid so here's the
white solid on the bottom of the beaker
and the solids at equilibrium with the
ions in solutions that would be pb2 plus
and cl minus notice how the mole ratio
is one to two of pb2 plus to two cl
minus so if we have two pb two plus ions
in our in our diagram there should be
twice as many chloride anions at
equilibrium the rate of dissolution is
equal to the rate of precipitation
therefore the concentration of ions in
solution remains constant
so our system is at equilibrium and
let's add some solid potassium chloride
potassium chloride is a soluble salt so
it will dissociate and turn into k plus
and cl minus in solution
adding a source of chloride anion means
the system is no longer at equilibrium
so let me write in here not at
equilibrium at that moment in time so
the system was at equilibrium and a
stress was added to the system in this
case the stress was increased chloride
anion so there's an increase in the
concentration of cl minus
according to le chatelier's principle
the system will move in the direction
that decreases the stress so if the
stress is increased concentration of
chloride anion the system will move to
the left to get rid of some of that
extra chloride anion when the system
moves to the left pb2 plus ions will
combine with chloride anions to form
pbcl2 and we can see that down here in
the diagram so imagine say this pb2 plus
ion combined with these two chloride
anions to form some more of the white
solid
looking at the third diagram the amount
of white solid has increased from the
second diagram and we've lost this pb2
plus ion and these two chloride anions
and the amount of our precipitate pbcl2
will keep forming until equilibrium is
reached let's just say this third
diagram does represent the system at
equilibrium so i'll write in here at
equilibrium this is an example of the
common ion effect for this problem the
common ion is the chloride anion because
there were two sources of it
one was was from the dissolution of
pbcl2 if we had dissolved some solid to
make a saturated solution the source of
these chloride anions would be from
pbcl2 and the second source is from the
added kcl which of course dissolves to
form chloride anion so the chloride
anion is the common ion
and we use le chatelier's principle to
predict the system will move to the left
to get rid of the extra chloride anion
when the system moved to the left we
formed more of the solid pbcl2 and
that's why this amount got bigger over
here so if we compare the first diagram
with the third diagram
the first diagram has more of the lead
ii chloride in solution
and the third diagram has less of it
therefore the addition of the common ion
of chloride anion that decreased the
solubility of lead to chloride so the
common ion effect says that the
solubility of a slightly soluble salt
like lead ii chloride is decreased by
the presence of a common ion
another way to think about this is using
the reaction quotient q
for the diagram on the left we're at
equilibrium therefore the reaction
quotient qsp is equal to the ksp value
for lead to chloride which means the
system is at equilibrium
adding chloride anion increases the
value for qsp so now qsp is greater than
ksp and the system is not at equilibrium
in order to decrease the value for q the
system needs to move to the left and the
system will continue to move to the left
until qsp is equal to ksp again and the
system is at equilibrium
a shift to the left means an increase in
the amount of pb cl2 which therefore
decreases the solubility of pbcl2
but it doesn't change the value for ksp
ksp for pbcl2 stays the same at the same
temperature
next let's see how the presence of a
common ion affects the molar solubility
of lead ii chloride and to do that let's
calculate the molar solubility of lead
ii chloride at 25 degrees celsius in a
solution that is 0.10 molar in potassium
chloride the ksp value for lead ii
chloride at 25 degrees celsius is 1.7
times 10 to the negative fifth to help
us calculate the molar solubility we're
going to use an ice table where i stands
for the initial concentration c is the
change in concentration and e is the
equilibrium concentration first let's
say that none of the lead ii chloride
has dissolved yet and if that's true the
concentration of lead two plus ions
would be zero and the concentration of
chloride anions from the lead ii
chloride would also be zero
however there's another source of
chloride anions and that's because our
solution is 0.10 molar in kcl kcl is a
soluble salt so kcl dissociates
completely to turn to k plus and cl
minus
therefore if the concentration of kcl is
0.10 molar that's also the concentration
of cl minus from the kcl so we can add
here plus
0.10 molar
and think about that as being from our
kcl so there are two sources there's
going to be two sources of chloride
anions here and so the cl anion is our
common ion the other source of chloride
anion is pbcl2 when it dissolves so some
of the pbcl2 will dissolve we don't know
how much so i like to write minus x in
here and if some of that dissolves the
mole ratio of pbcl2 to pb2 plus is a one
to one mole ratio so for losing x for
pbcl2 we're gaining x for pb2 plus
and looking at our mole ratios if we're
gaining x for pv2 plus and it's a 1 to 2
mole ratio we would write in here plus
2x for the chloride anion so for the
equilibrium concentration of pb2 plus it
would be 0 plus x or just x and for the
equilibrium concentration of the
chloride anion it would be 0.10 plus 2x
so the 0.10
came from the potassium chloride and the
2x came from the dissolution of lead ii
chloride
next we need to write a ksp expression
which we can get from the dissolution
equation so ksp is equal to the
concentration of lead two plus ions
raised to the first power times the
concentration of chloride anions and
since there's a two as a coefficient in
the balanced equation we need to raise
that concentration to the second power
pure solids are left out of equilibrium
constant expressions so we don't write
anything for pbcl2
next we plug in our equilibrium
concentrations so for lead two plus the
equilibrium concentration is x and for
the chloride anion the equilibrium
concentration is 0.10
plus 2x
we're also we also need to plug in the
ksp value for lead 2 chloride here we
have the ksp value plugged in x and 0.10
plus 2x now let's think about 0.10 plus
2x for a second here with a very low
value for ksp 1.7 times 10 to the
negative fifth that means that not very
much of the pbcl2 will dissolve and if
that's true x is a pretty small number
and if x is a small number 2x is also
pretty small so we're going to make an
approximation and say that .10 plus a
pretty small number is approximately
equal to just .10
and that's going to make the math easier
on us so instead of writing 0.10 plus 2x
squared we just have 0.10 squared
solving for x we find that x is equal to
0.0
which we could just write as 1.7 times
10 to the negative third molar it's okay
to write molar here because this this x
value represents the equilibrium
concentration of pb2 plus
and if that's the equilibrium
concentration of pb2 plus that's also
the concentration of lead ii chloride
that dissolved so this number this
concentration is the molar solubility of
lead to chloride in a solution at 25
degrees where the solution is 0.10 molar
in kcl
most textbooks leave this minus x out of
their ice tables because the
concentration of a solid doesn't change
i like to just leave it in here though
to remind me that x represents the molar
solubility of the slightly soluble salt
finally if we calculate the molar
solubility of lead ii chloride without
the presence of a common ion this .10
would have been gone from everything and
doing the math that way we would have
found that the molar solubility at 25
degrees celsius and using these using
this value for the ksp the molar
solubility comes out to
0.01
six molar
so comparing these two molar
solubilities point zero one six molar
versus point zero zero one seven there's
that's approximately a factor of ten
therefore the addition of a common ion
decreased the solubility by
approximately a factor of 10. so doing
the common ion effect in a quantitative
way also shows a decrease in the
solubility of a slightly soluble salt
by the presence because of the presence
of a common ion